so there's some pretty funny coveted
hijinks going on this is not the most
serious thing but it just shows how
petty everybody is and to some degree i
kind of like it and at least as far as
joe biden's concerned as many of you
know joe biden recently had coveted and
there were some on the right we covered
allison steinberg and some others who
seemed sort of happy that joe biden had
covid they weren't straight up saying i
hope he dies and doesn't recover but
they certainly seem to be implying it
and yesterday president joe biden
returned to work officially announced
that he has tested negative for covid
his isolation can now end and that it
was mild all along
hello everyone
i've uh
just tested negative
for cover 19 after isolating for five
days
[Applause]
so those hoping for the demise of joe
biden due to covet unfortunately will be
disappointed but here's where it gets
petty and kind of funny
joe biden brought up this is just so
funny it's apropos of nothing
biden contrasted
his covet case where
it was mild
he didn't need oxygen he didn't get
helicoptered to walter reed for fears
that he would soon be unable to walk
under his own power you might remember
we later learned that when trump got
covered suddenly there was this
announcement oh he's being helicoptered
to walter reed what's going on
and we later learned that doctors and
advisors came to him and with tears in
their eyes they said sir you might want
to go to walter reed now because the way
this is going uh we may have to take you
there in a stretcher at some point and
trump didn't want the optics of that so
he flew to walter reed and biden just
kind of made fun of of trump for lack of
a better term that's really what he did
here here's the bottom line
when my predecessor got covered he had
to get helicopter to walter reed medical
center he was severely ill thankfully he
recovered
when i got coped i worked from upstairs
to the white house and the office is
upstairs and for the that five-day
period
the difference is vaccinations of course
but also three new tools free to all and
widely available you don't need to be
president to get these tools to be used
for your defense right here's the bottom
line the point here is really to talk
about vaccines right the argument that
joe biden is making is
trump wasn't vaccinated and he had a
really serious case
i am vaccinated and i had a very mild
case now
these are not
really great arguments there's a bunch
of different things number one
biden physically seems healthier than
trump i mean let's be honest we know
trump's not really 63 239 uh trump is is
obese
uh eats very unhealthy diet generally
okay so that predisposes trump to have a
more serious case than biden first and
foremost secondly these are different
variants and i am not making i don't
have the latest numbers as to whether ba
five the current variant uh in terms of
hospitalization risk or whatever you
know and then you have to account for
the fact that yes it there could be a
different hospitalization risk but
when vaccinated what is the net
likelihood of being hospitalized now
versus back when trump had there's all
of this different stuff what's funny
about it
is biden just wants to make the point
that thanks to vaccines he had a mild
case compared to trump's serious case
but the funny thing is that it comes off
as again trump just wants to be the
alpha and the best and the strongest at
absolutely everything
and it seems like biden is kind of
ribbing him and you know that it
triggers trump very very badly now the
the third layer that's really funny
is
sean hannity then pops up out of nowhere
to then run cover for trump about okay
trump went to walter reed
but that was a much stronger strain
and again this is all bs it's all a
penis size contest but everybody's
playing their role and hannity pops up
as the trump defender titan had to evoke
the uniter that he is his favorite
subject donald trump take a look
here's the bottom line
when my predecessor got covered he had
to get helicoptered to walter reed
medical center he was severely ill
thankfully he recovered
when i got coveted i worked from
upstairs to the white house and the
office is upstairs and for the that five
day period
the difference is vaccinations of course
now what joe failed to mention is the
current variant which is ba 5 the
dominant variant of omicron is much much
weaker than the original strain that
infected then president trump right
don't think for a second that biden is
any better stronger
smarter
faster
nicer more intelligent whatever than
trump trump got hit with a hard variant
per virologist sean hannity whereas
biden got a weak variant and was
vaccinated i guess to some degree
hannity is kind of saying that the
vaccines work so anyway it's just all a
pissing match it really is but something
about it i found actually pretty funny
joe biden is back we're all glad to see
that